un demonio que esconde una geisha un
perro
y hasta el recuerdo para una madre los
hay de todos los tamaños y colores te
identifican te valora te relaciona te da
un algo distinto que es lo que la gente
que estamos tatuados buscamos vernos
distintos Nosotros somos un lienzos que
coleccionamos los mejores piezas de los
mejores tatuadores entonces para
nosotros es un ser un Lienzo y llevar
nuestra piel los mejores lienzos y todo
ha sido este fin de semana la capital
mundial del tatuaje una práctica que
tiene miles de años de antigüedad y
millones de adeptos para algunos
tatuarse es una terapia yo tengo muchos
clientes que cuando están atravesando
algo durante su vida alguna ruptura
alguna cosa se quieren tatuar que es
como una especie de ritual donde uno
sana empatiza con el tatuador se libera
el evento además contó con un invitado
especial el francés Anthony lofredo
conocido como Black alliant por las
modificaciones en su cuerpo con las que
busca asemejarse a un extraterrestre es
un proyecto que yo tengo de este pequeño
de cambiar mi cuerpo
porque lo salles me llaman mucho la
atención la vida afuera de la planeta me
llama mucho la atención Yo me pregunto
siempre todos los días si hay algo fuera
que existe para mí sí es como mi
creyente
es como si esta edición el encuentro
tiene por objetivo hacer pedagogía sobre
el universo del tatuaje y romper los
temores que todavía rodean a este arte